[musique]
Vous devez garder le Rokka d'origine dans votre maison et le stocker là-bas.
n'est-ce pas
Le casier lui-même est un casier
faut garder
Après ça, si je cassais le casier et prenais une arme, ce serait mal si je pouvais tirer.
J'ai également démonté l'intérieur.
Si vous l'assemblez dans le même casier, vous ne pourrez pas faire l'intérieur.
[musique]
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
vaudou
Ben
[musique]
Je suis
avait
Il y a des histoires sur le fait de pouvoir être instructeur dès l'âge de 10 ans, puis de devenir lycéen et de choisir soigneusement dans les airs.
Quand tu veux le posséder parce que tu l'as reçu
détective
le
Je viendrai demander autour de la maison où y a un enfant qui veut posséder
Quel genre d'enfant es-tu
ce sera transparent
[musique]